police are searching for the suspect in
a hit-and-run crash that left a teenager
dead thank you for joining us tonight at
six o'clock i'm sasha loftis this
happened near durango and warm springs
last night the teen which we now know
was 15 years old died at the hospital
eight news now reporter victoria saha
joins us live in that area with the
latest details victoria
sasha just a tragic situation but we are
learning today that two teens were
crossing trying to cross here on the
eastbound on south durango drive but it
wasn't their turn to cross just yet they
were going against the pedestrian signal
at the same time cars coming on the
northbound lane here on
durango
that car hit that teen and then drove
off
it was the worst thing i've ever
experienced in my life desiree
andreessen saw the whole incident unfold
just as she was sitting at the traffic
light near rhodes ranch the car was
going so fast and
didn't even tap his brakes after it
happened it just kept going on saturday
morning metro police released
information saying two juveniles were
trying to cross durango drive against
the pedestrian signal the first juvenile
made it over as the second one crossed
it came in front of a car that hit the
teen the impact was so big that he flew
on the other side of the road and
landed almost in front of my car
andreessen says she stayed on scene the
entire time letting police know what she
saw the other little kid was saying
that's my brother my brother and was
trying to get him and wake him up and
that yeah that's what will not leave my
mind the 15 year old teen was rushed to
umc trauma where he was pronounced dead
police are still looking for a red dodge
charger the model could be from 2015 to
2017 it is missing a left side mirror
and could have some damage to its
windshield so please keep an eye out if
you do spot this car call police i also
want to add that sierra vista high
school is just up the road here there
was a football game last night and that
witness that you just heard from
andreessen she did say that the teens
were crossing this way it looked like
they were walking towards the school
reporting live victoria saha 8 news now